[Music]
we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three two one
here
there's five g's
i wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story worthy of a sequel
and until technology evolved so we could
delve deeper into the experience of a
fighter pilot
the first movie became something that
changed a generation
so this is exciting to come back and get
in those jets again
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
it's intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there tom designed this
all-encompassing aviation training for
all the actors
i started mounting a single-engine
airplane to build up their spatial
awareness inside the aircraft
next we took them to the l-39 and they
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a jet
speed
from there they'd graduate to the f-18
super hornet and actually launching off
an aircraft carrier
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay
i had to really teach them
cinematography and the lighting so that
they understood what's going to look
good on camera
is great everybody thought it would be
impossible for actors to really be in
the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it
definitely the most amazing thing i've
ever done all the training 100
i'm very proud of what we all accomplish
each one of them are extraordinary
it still blows my mind that we've done
this
there's nothing like it
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blocked
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
with all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning
aviators this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come
[Music]
on yet
[Music]
[Music]
you